(playful music)
- [Narrator] Volcanic
corruptions like this
may look mesmerizing and sometimes
attract flux of tourists,
but they're also dangerous events
that impact human activities,
displace people, and cost lives.
- The prediction is that we
did lose some 50% of our GDP
as a result of the volcanic eruption.
- [Narrator] Take this volcano
on the Caribbean island of St. Vincent.
No deaths were reported, but
many people had to evacuate
and ash blanketed entire neighborhoods.
Or this Icelandic volcano
that erupted in 2010,
paralyzing air traffic
and costing nearly $5
billion to global GDP.
So far, tools like seismicity monitors
have allowed volcanologists
to forecast unrest
days or weeks in advance,
but now NASA scientists say
they can help forecast eruptions
months or even years ahead of
time using satellite imagery
and monitoring changes
in ground temperature.
- We wanted to understand
to what extent the heat released
by volcanoes can be used
to detect when volcanoes
start to reactivate.
There are many impacts
of volcanic eruptions
and our goal is to minimize those impacts
as much as possible.
- [Narrator] So here's how it works
and how scientists say we could benefit
from this new research.
An early sign of a
volcanic eruption is heat,
as the magma underground rises,
bringing warm gases to the surface.
- We see that these heat
emissions, they start to appear
for several months to
years before eruption
and we observe these signals prior
to the changes that we observe
with other types of signals.
- [Narrator] The problem is
that these heat emissions
can be hard to monitor on the ground,
So Girona and his team turned to the sky.
NASA satellites have
already been recording
years of information on thermal activity.
- In fact, none of these
satellites have been designed
specifically to explore volcanoes,
but we can still use that information
for monitoring volcanic eruptions.
- [Narrator] After looking at two decades
of radiant heat data
for several volcanoes,
the researchers found a pattern.
In the years leading up to interruption,
temperatures increased
over much of each volcano
before dropping again after the eruption.
- [Tarsilo] We are detecting
the early reactivation
of the volcano, which is crucial
to improve the monitoring efforts.
- [Narrator] But before this technology
can be fully deployed in the real world,
scientists will have to
process much more data.
- Hopefully in a few years,
we can have a better
understanding of the signals,
better understanding of volcanoes,
and we can provide accurate forecasts.
- [Narrator] With about 1,500
active volcanoes on Earth
and troves of satellite
data for each one of them,
the NASA team is seeking help
from algorithms and other
researchers around the world.
- This is another tool in our toolbox.
- [Narrator] That's Mike Poland.
He's a geophysicist for
the U.S. Geological Survey.
He says that these satellite
images will have to be used
in tandem with other traditional methods.
- If you're building a house,
you don't just show up with a screwdriver.
You've got a screwdriver, a hammer, a saw,
and we need a diverse toolkit
so that we can recognize all
the different types of signs
that volcanoes might be giving us.
- [Narrator] Seismometers gas, sensors,
and radar sensors are some of the tools
that volcanologists will continue to use.
Giving communities more time to prepare
could make the difference between
saving livelihoods or not.
In St. Vincent, the local
observatory noticed signs
of unrest weeks in advance
and officials were ready to
evacuate 20,000 residents
before the volcano erupted,
helping to avoid casualties
and greater damage.
But with even more warning,
officials say they may have
been able to avoid damage
such as water contamination, for example.
- When the massive
eruption there took place,
it compromised our entire water supply.
All of our reservoirs were
contaminated with ash.
We were without water for a couple of days
and perhaps going forward,
we can look at maybe putting in tents
where persons can store water properly.
We have to look at greater mitigation
where natural disasters are concerned.
- [Narrator] And in the case
of that Icelandic volcano,
scientists say that more warning
would have given the aviation
industry more time to adapt
and find alternative routes.
- It's important to forecast eruptions
because we can reduce the
impact at a local scale,
but also at a global scale
if you're talking about
much larger eruptions.
(tranquil futuristic music)